the kardashian jenners are taking a
thoughtful trip down memory lane
you have no idea in a new clip from the
keeping up with kardashian's reunion
kim chris chloe courtney and kendall
share what advice they'd give to their
younger selves
i mean you have no idea because like i
really had no idea like what was going
to like happen in my life
like where i was trusted just trust and
like literally have faith in the
universe that was i
have faith in god yeah plan for you and
trust was a common theme within the
group but for kim kardashian
it wasn't with other people i would say
don't be so trusting
and but still have that you know your
open heart
and trusting another trust the universe
kris jenner's answer seems obvious
telling her younger self that she would
you guessed it
trust the universe with her family's
multi-million dollar brand
i think trust the way things are gonna
work out is gonna be for the best
it really started a trend
trust isn't the worst thing and there's
also one more thing most of them can
agree on when it comes to their former
fashion choices
i've already told my younger self
just ditch some of the outfits yeah
crazy outfits i can't mommy your outfits
are iconic mine i had green jeans on
most of the shows oh my god
my accessories the hats and the
headbands
oh the turbans the turbans i want to
bring
back a scott suit with a scarf and again
earlier this month the 20th and final
season of keeping up with the
kardashians
came to an end
you know i think the fireworks it was
definitely a weird moment because it was
kind of like
an amazing moment for the kids amazing
moment for the adults but at the same
time
kind of felt like the end of an era
although keeping up may be over we still
have the two-part reunion to look
forward to
where the kardashian jenners sit down
with andy cohen to discuss some of the
most iconic moments from their 14-year
run
why is the show coming to an end we're
all feeling a little overwhelmed we had
done it for so long
what people don't know is you said to me
i'm gonna put you in a car and no one
will find you
just leave and i'll take care of it and
don't forget this won't be the last time
we'll see the famous family on our tv
screens
as they are set to star in a brand new
show coming to hulu
in 2021 in 2017 kim told et why she
loves working with her family
i just think like we're definitely a
close family like
more than probably normal but having a
show where we have to work together we
have to
be together i mean i think it just
brings us
[Music]
closer
[Music]
you